this evening we are in brazil and in
london to assess what some are calling
an historic deal and others are calling
a failure what is the future of the
planet after glasgow
[Music]
so
good evening from rio de janeiro in
brazil a country so central to the fight
against climate change and from where we
have been reporting for two weeks now
while politicians and diplomats wrangle
over the agreement in glasgow if it is
all about political will and it is
clearly lacking here right now then that
will be the test of the agreement around
the world on this special program
the prime minister hails the glasgow
climate pact signed by almost 200
countries
we finally came to the kind of
game-changing agreement that the world
needed to see
india and china force a last minute
change to the agreement calling for the
phase down and not the phase out of coal
we report on what that could mean for
some of the world's most vulnerable
people madagascar
on the brink of a climate change famine
and how the illegal beef trade is
destroying the amazon rainforest often
called the lungs of the planet
i'm sally lockwood in london we'll be
assessing what an agreement that brought
even the cop president alok sharma to
tears means for the future of our planet
i apologize for
the way this process has unfolded
and
i'm deeply sorry
well first there was the intense down to
the wire haggling over the agreement now
there is little consensus over how good
or how bad the deal is first this
evening our science and technology
editor tom clark looks at what is now
being called the glasgow climate pact
if passion could save the planet climate
change would have been fixed decades ago
[Music]
young people are leading the movement
for change look at this young people are
banging the drums there's so much
happening outside and if only people
would listen to this it's incredible if
we don't act no then our planet
could be in
real danger the leaders arriving in
glasgow couldn't have failed to notice
the voices on the streets and at climate
summit that clamour followed them inside
the un cop isn't like the elite talking
shops of davos and the g20 here the
world that's grown or is growing rich
from fossil fuels is confronted by its
peers who are suffering at their expense
so i ask to you
what must we say to our people
living on the front line in the
caribbean
in africa in latin america in the
pacific
when both ambition
and regrettably some of the needed faces
at glasgow are not
present what excuse
should we give for the failure
but the delegates here knew that the
political realities of getting 197
nations to work together on a climate
pact meant failure was always a very
real prospect
the uk government orchestrated a raft of
ambition raising deals to cut coal
methane and aid for fossil fuels and
mobilize cash
they may cut a few tenths of degree of
global warming important but a sideshow
to the main event delivering on the
paris agreement and by some measures
to focus minds president obama a veteran
of paris stopped by
we are nowhere near where we need to be
yet
for starters despite the progress that
paris represented most countries have
failed to meet the action plans that
they set six years ago
and the consequences of not moving fast
enough are becoming more apparent all
the time
apparent or not many countries who
depend on fossil fuels seemed happy to
ignore them at the negotiating table
you wouldn't admit it in public you must
have your own comments not serious
allegations these are
fabricated allegations they are
fabricated allegations
in the final hours of the negotiations
china india and others made the move
many had feared
so something's definitely going on here
the plenary was meant to start an hour
ago yet instead despite alex sharma
trying to call countries to order to sit
down and begin the formal process
they broke up into huddles negotiations
are going on
and everyone's looking around trying to
figure out what on earth's happening
their play was to defend coal and fossil
fuel subsidies ruthless but it belies
some important realities phasing out
fossil fuels too fast would be unjust
take ukraine which pledged to end coal
by 2035. at the same time it's not an
easy process we have
65 percent of people who actually rely
on subsidies from the government for the
energy poverty they cannot afford their
bills
and with the
fluctuations on the market this year
it's extremely difficult it's it's
extremely difficult for many people
in the end alok sharma had to go against
the science and the demands of young
people
i also understand the the deep
disappointment
but i think as you have noted
it's also vital that we
protect this package
the deal was weakened but not destroyed
and time had run out i propose that this
decision be adopted as amended
hearing no objections it is so decided
it is exactly what the demonstrators at
cop 26 had worried about and the deal
also failed to secure the funding the
most vulnerable countries needed most
it's a death sentence
for the poorest people on the planet and
not only that the polluters are saying
to hell with you we don't care we're not
going to give you a penny
so very disappointed
i'm disappointed i'm angry
as you can see
no deal was going to dismantle
late-stage capitalism and close the gap
between the global north and south and
the one agreed here doesn't even cut
emissions by enough or agree to
compensate those who are going to suffer
as a result it's a feeble compromise but
it's not a failure
the pack signed here recognizes we're in
an emergency and it does lay the
foundations for what the world plans to
do about it
i feel very hopeful i mean at the
beginning of this process two weeks ago
i did not think we'd get this far i
think at the very end there was a little
bit of a wrinkle and that's hard to
swallow when it's so emotional
everyone's in the room together and and
it's very heavy it feels like a lot but
if you told me two weeks ago that we
would have got this i never would have
believed you and i'm very heartened by
the way that the whole world has come
together because they recognize they
need to do more for climate action and
keep 1.5 degrees in sight
in sight but still far from reach
they're packing up this vast climate
negotiation road show before it moves to
shameless shake in 2022
if the ambition there is even greater
than it was in glasgow we could be in
with a chance
albeit a very small one
tom clark sky news glasgow
right let's go to some of the countries
involved in all this india was the
nation that proposed the last minute
amendment to weaken uh the language on
coal katarina patosi is in chennai in
india katarina
yes i think when we step back and
reflect on the past two weeks of this
cop conference it will be that
intervention by the indian delegation in
the dying hours of the summit which will
really stick in the memory because it
was in that moment that the summit which
had this lofty ambition to consign call
to the history books saw that hope start
to slowly but surely fade away such a
simple change in vocabulary from a cold
phase out to a coal phase down whether
you see this as india gambling with the
climate crisis or rather just being
pragmatic about its own energy security
it's something which is deeply
significant we've spent the day here in
chennai a city on india's southern coast
that has seen many millions of people
affected by climate change to guess and
assess the latest reaction from india
thousands of miles away from chennai a
decision was made that will affect this
warming city
in glasgow india pushed for the
continued use of a fossil fuel that
makes climates change
campaigner vishvaja was at cop 26 and
arrived home this morning
so immediately after landing when i got
to see about
the term change from phase out to face
down
it was a total disappointment
it seems like for world leaders
any world leaders
people or humanity or
other life forms nothing matters for
them it's corporates it's business it's
money
and it includes india also
india has always occupied a rather
unique space around the cop negotiating
table yes it's seen as an emerging and
developing country but it's also the
world's third largest polluter
historically though its carbon emissions
compared to developed nations is still
low and that is why india has fought
successfully for that change in the
fossil fuel text is telling the world we
want our fair slice of the carbon pie
do you think it was fair of india to
change the text around fossil fuels and
around coal
last thing the world should do is doubt
india's commitment towards the cause we
are really showing up
our actions in what we are doing but we
have to be very feasible in our
in our actions but we definitely have to
look at our other priority which is to
pull back a lot of people who still do
not have the access to basics if you
look at the 10 percent the global 10
percent of the population has consumed a
large share of the carbon budget and we
still have millions under poverty i
think that's not fair
and india's poorest without coal would
go
it's an issue campaigners say the
developed nations have failed to hear a
cop or properly finance
the global north have all the privileges
and
the the problems relies on the global
south but the voices from the global
south are are not heard like how they
have to be heard
but as if on ironic queue over india's
capital a smog has fallen
fueled in part by surrounding coal power
plants and this will only get worse as
domestic coal production is going up to
keep energy prices low
the stance of the in the indian
government asking the rich and developed
nations to put up the money is very
justified
but asking for
continuing the mining and burning of
coal and fossil fuel is irresponsible
and not just for the for the world but
also for india and china and the people
who live around these
disaster zones
but even from these areas there is
little pressure on the government to
change its position
when india does phase down cold it'll be
on its own terms
and on its own timetable
catering for toxicity sky news india
well the bahamas is one of the small
island nations most exposed to rising
temperatures rising sea levels and
extreme weather mark stone is in the
bahamas for us right now mark
mark a few days ago i spoke to the prime
minister of this archipelago nation and
he told me then he was worried about the
language from the glasgow conference
that it lacked teeth and that it was
purely aspirational and that was before
the wording on coal had been watered
down this is one of so many small
developing island nations where they are
disappointed and they are worried they
wanted much more firm commitments on
funding to help them deal with the
consequences of ever more extreme
weather and they know that if the
warming planet is not
it's not slowed down then there may well
not be a future for these islands on the
edge
beyond glasgow beyond the ambition the
forests of great abaco have gone
the storm was two years ago and yet for
mile after mile it still looks like this
a wasteland
and the communities around have hardly
rebuilt
and do you remember
the storm very well yes sir it was very
bad it's something i'll never want to
experience again
zander gardner is just 18 showing us
around an island that puts the cop
conference and his future in context
this right there this is this was
actually a school the money to rebuild
from the bahamas most powerful storm on
record never came
it's a long journey but
we'll make it
marsh harbor feels forgotten frozen in
that moment two years ago
beyond the sound of a slow rebuild
everyone here wonders what the future
holds
in glasgow the jargon is loss and damage
and adaptation finance a push by island
nations like this to demand the big
polluting countries pay for the
consequences here and the text agreed on
is they say disappointing mechanisms but
no commitments and it's not just the
destruction but the displacement
so your mom lives down here
okay
maybe we can go and meet her these pods
are temporary homes for all those who've
lost theirs
what about you know the next storm
because that must be such a worry that
another one will come
i know i'm gonna be here
i had to go
go somewhere else
where the weather's better
where the weather is better
what's clear is that today's internally
displaced at tomorrow's refugees they
become another nation's burden
how long have you been here
a few pods down 21 year old dominique
invites us into her temporary home
wow look at this crab it's lunchtime and
mom gardenia is cooking any little rain
or thunders they hear like my nephews
you can see like they're a little scared
and they go back to thinking about it so
just trying to get back in some housing
that's gonna i wanna say hopefully
protect us if another hurricane was to
pass her again chatting to dominique
it's clear that she's no time to think
about the climate science or the
culprits because she is living it right
now for her what matters is her family's
survival and existence
and that's sad to say but that's the
honest truth
but now that we're talking about that
and how you're telling me about the
conference trust me i'm definitely gonna
look that up
the weather changes fast here it's
hurricane season and they're holding
their breath
up the coast is the fishing community of
cooper's town
a break in the rain is a chance for a
chat with local firefighter kirk murray
a man clearly scarred by what he
experienced two years ago but not
defeated you know we if we give up now
all hope is lost if we come together as
a country a neighboring country we could
all do this together so it's a fight
together because we're jessica up there
if they cough we catch the cold so if we
do this together we ain't nothing could
stop us
you know the really alarming thing is
that whatever the deal in glasgow
whether or not countries stick to their
pledges here it is probably already too
late even the most modest temperature
rise predictions would see sea level
rises of up to a meter and that would
put this entire island community
underwater
they are images not of the power of
nature but the consequence of our impact
on it an inability to protect against it
here they are beyond the pledges the
promises the compromises in glasgow mark
stone sky news in great abaco the
bahamas
back here in the uk we are all assessing
the agreement that was signed at cop26
speaking just a couple of hours ago an
optimistic prime minister hailed the
glasgow climate pact
all these world leaders came to glasgow
because their politicians are telling
them
that they need to act we've heard from
the individuals who are already living
with the effects and yesterday evening
we finally came to the kind of
game-changing agreement that the world
needed to see
and our political editor beth rigby
joins us now from downing street uh good
evening to you beth uh the prime
minister very much focusing on the
positives but he did accept that a full
solution to climate change hadn't been
delivered in glasgow
yes that's right sally
a little while before cop kicked off the
prime minister described this summit as
a turning point for humanity the moment
where we really began to tackle climate
change and in that press conference this
afternoon
he certainly tried to put a positive
spin on it he said it was a game changer
he said it had plotted the way ahead
with a road map to defeat
climate change but if we zoom out from
all the spin around it he also
acknowledged at that press conference
that with what's just happened in
glasgow the world is still on track to
warm up by two degrees centigrade by the
end of this century that is not what the
paris accord wanted they have not yet
met the goal set back in paris and while
the prime minister says that 1.5 is
still
alive there is so much more work to do
and for me really the person that summed
it up i thought very well was john kerry
the u.s climate envoy when he told the
conference as it closed that if paris
had built the stadium to deal with
climate change then glasgow started the
race to actually achieve it but whether
it was a success or not it won't be
decided on the basis of what happened in
the last few days it will be decided in
the coming months as countries do or
don't put forward more ambitious plans
to tackle climate change so after a very
difficult summit i think really it's all
eyes now on egypt on the next cop and
those exhausted negotiators now need to
pick up the baton once more and keep
running
beth thank you
well u.n secretary general antonio
guterres described the glasgow climate
pact as a compromise here's the
assessment of our science correspondent
thomas moore
so where does the glasgow climate pact
leave the planet well before the un
summit the real world action by
countries to cut greenhouse gas
emissions put us on course for 2.7
degrees of warming above pre-industrial
age temperatures by the end of this
century that's well above the one and a
half degrees the point at which most
scientists believe the climate will
become dangerously unstable
two weeks of negotiations have taken us
closer to that goal but we're still well
short
with the targets that countries are
committed to by 2030 we're heading for a
rise of around 2.4 degrees
even in the most optimistic scenario
where longer term and still woolly
commitments to net zero are taken into
account we're heading for an average
temperature rise of around 1.8 degrees
those small differences really matter
let's compare the world at one and a
half and two celsius a gap of just half
a degree well the number of people
around the world facing at least one
severe heat wave every five years would
rise from 420 million to 1.7 billion
lack of rain would increase the
population facing severe drought from
133 million to 195 million
rising sea levels would increase people
affected by coastal flooding from 60
million a year to 72 million a year by
2095 and hunger would increase as crop
yields fall for mays or corn down 6
with an even bigger drop of nine percent
at two degrees and it's not just humans
affected the proportion of insects that
lose most of the area they were like to
live in would rise from six percent to
eighteen percent and they underpin whole
food chains we are running out of time
to rain in global warming the average
temperature is up 1.2 degrees since
pre-industrial times and we've already
seen record high temperatures this year
in north america and the mediterranean
while in central europe there was
devastation caused by extreme rainfall
as the un secretary general has said
climate change is moving faster than we
are
thomas moore there well diplomats and
negotiating teams from some 200
countries came together in glasgow for
the summit as well as activists uh from
all over the world i would join now by
laurence tubiano who was climate change
ambassador to france special
representative for cop 21 paris and one
of the architects of the paris agreement
she now runs the european climate
foundation thank you very much for being
with us a simple question really was
glasgow a success or a failure
i think we cannot respond uh either way
it is to stop the progress since paris
it
shows that
pressure works that paris agreement
works but at the same time we have to
recognize that we are running
running beyond time we are we are really
running out of time to tackle uh the
problem we are facing and that probably
is a
semi feel some if
the glass is half full half empty and in
particularly of course empty as we hear
many delegations in glasgow from less
developed countries and small line and
in particular say
the count was not for them
so in a way we see emerging countries we
see developed countries at least commit
to something we will have of course to
see much more for next year but the loss
and damage issue which is this image
presented in your in in your your
broadcast is are really stunning and
it's not tomorrow it's just today so i
think uh glasgow for me is a message of
acceleration
yeah i mean because the question is i
guess if you
were an island nation that is eroding
fast would you
say that this was a success
i don't think they can say that they
feel even they have been left behind by
developing countries
which finally didn't want to commit on
really have a mechanism a financial
mechanism for loss and damage and
recognizing final year even if it's a
broad responsibility the responsibility
of what is happening to them so i feel
for them it's not a success and we have
to demonstrate that their point of view
has been picked up and if we could not
be ready to agree on loss and damage
funding these at this cup we have to
consider seriously for next year and on
the top of that we need really two
countries to commit to more environments
yeah and just finally the environment of
the maldives says and he said the
difference between 1.5 degrees and
2 degrees for us is a death sentence
yeah absolutely and they have said now
that many many years the prime minister
of barbados
just said
at the beginning of the of the talks
really when we will have enough of this
uh image of terrible catastrophes and
probably we are not have seen enough of
them
okay laurence toubiana thank you very
much indeed uh for being with us well
one australian senator described the
change of language in the glasgow
climate pact as a huge win for coal the
country is the world's second largest
exporter between 2018 and 19 the total
value of coal exports from australia was
nearly 70 billion dollars most of the
coal for foreign markets is produced in
the hunter valley in new south wales the
state mines around 40 percent of all
coal production in australia sky
correspondent siobhan robbins reports
from moswell brook in the upper hunter
valley
on the country's coal dependency
this is coal country
in the hunter valley a 13 000 strong
workforce dig and mine this land
australians building fortunes and
futures from the black gold they pull
from the earth
coal is so important to this area to
this community we believe that we've got
another 30 years left of this industry
to continue uh selling coal all around
the world so the last piece of coal
that's burnt in the world should be
hunna valley black coal if we turned off
coal now what would happen here we would
see social devastation
and in terms of jobs lost
businesses going bankrupt and people
moving away from this area
[Music]
this community isn't just built on coal
it's intertwined in the very fabric of
society
people have given their lives to the
mines
the mines have given livelihoods to tens
of thousands of people
australia may have backed the cop
agreement to phase down coal without a
deadline but it dodged an earlier pledge
to cut it completely next decade a move
supported by many here unfortunately
with this green movement one of the
major sacrifices has been our
manufacturing we don't manufacture
anything in this country anymore that's
all been exported to china so we have
very little left in this country as far
as income and this is a major one and
now they want to kill it off along with
everything else so are you willing to
roll the dice and
risk
potentially the planet dying no i'm not
saying that we should do nothing there
are things that we can do to reduce the
carbon output but i don't think that
putting a switch in which is going to
act like a nuclear bomb on our economies
is a good idea
this is the side of the house that faces
all of the bides but this has gotten
worse
but even in coal country fears over
pollution and climate change have
started causing divisions
so what is that that you're wiping off
coldest it makes me angry it makes me
worried i mean that's in my lungs too
margo's family once made its money from
mining
but for australia to have a future she
thinks coal has to be left in the past
the government has boosted solar and
wind power pledged net zero emissions by
2050
but it's also signed off new mines
we're about to dig up more dirt
and and dig up more tons of coal for
many more years we just can't be doing
it anymore for the climate i think
the bill has sounded and it is time for
the
coal industries to start transitioning
out of it
this isn't just a domestic battle
australia is the world's second biggest
exporter of coal
a global dealer of the planet's
filthiest fossil fuel
these communities have fought and died
for coal if australia bows to pressure
what happens to the people living here
if it doesn't what happens to the rest
of the world
is this a curtain call for coal
no i don't believe it is i mean have a
look in the backdrop of
uh cop you've got record high cold
demand all around the world so if there
was a last stand to be made on coal it
should be here in this country
in the shadow of cops first ever coal
commitments australia is now facing its
most important power struggle
the balance of energy economics and the
environment struck here will impact all
our lives
well climate campaigners have slammed
australia as a laggard for failing to
come to the conference with improved
2030 emissions targets failing to show
any desire to move quickly away from
coal but mining communities i've spoken
to have welcomed the glasgow pack saying
it will make little difference to
australia that they believe they'll be
pulling coal out of the grounds here in
30 years and one pro coal senator told
sky news glasgow was a win for the
fossil fuel
the agreement um that's come out
of glasgow overnight is a green light
for more coal production that's what
india wanted
that's why it didn't agree to the
original text which wanted to see
coal phase down completely and that's
good news for the world because it might
be the most important thing for the
world to do uh over the next few decades
is to bring more and more people out of
poverty uh and coal and cheap energy
helps do that
situation there in australia but while
world leaders have been meeting in
glasgow sky news has been reporting from
around the world on the impact of
climate change right now and how a
failure to get a meaningful agreement on
carbon emissions at cop 26 would put
already vulnerable people at even
greater risk the indian ocean island of
madagascar has been experiencing the
worst drought in 40 years children are
slowly dying of hunger as their mothers
plead for help our special correspondent
alex crawford and her team report now
from ambavambi in southern madagascar on
what the united nations is saying could
become the world's first climate change
famine
they're digging for water having to
scoop holes in the sand until waist deep
to try to get to the water table
and there are thousands doing this on
what was once a river and not a small
one at that
it's the starkest image of how severely
climate change is affecting madagascar
and from our drone pictures the snaking
sand scar goes on and on and on
they dig because there is no water this
is all they have for drinking washing
cooking after the worst extended drought
in 40 years
and this is a country which basically
gets around on this carts not many of
them in comparison to the population
have access to cars they don't even have
access to electricity only about 15
of the country have access to
electricity so they're one of the lowest
emitters of carbon
emissions in the world and yet they are
the country which is
really feeling the most impact with the
un declaring that parts of the country
are on the brink of tipping into famine
climate change is killing and malalaza
is one of madagascar's younger victims
she's barely got the strength to turn
her head
she's the weight of a typical newborn
she's actually a year and two months old
with few reserves to fight disease
she's now got tuberculosis but is too
weak to cry and protest very much
she's living and slowly dying in the
country likely to go down in history as
the first to suffer from a climate
change famine
the health workers have few weapons to
fight this environmental war
and without a shot being fired they're
seeing suffering on a huge scale and
they are losing with the bulk of the
country so poor they're struggling to
get enough to eat
the weekly clinic in above is crowded
with mothers and hungry children with
acute malnutrition
here a swollen stomach is the sign of
suffering and hunger nearly 90 percent
of the country live below the poverty
line earning less than two dollars a day
they're one of the poorest countries in
the world
[Music]
soldiers lusty crying's a good sign it
means the little girl's strong enough to
fight and a small victory she's gained
weight
her mother smiles for the first time
i'm very happy she tells us
[Music]
the young are the most vulnerable
madagascar is battling after years of
failed or poor crops caused by this
extended dry period
and this aid is their only hope of
survival
they give thanks to the aid agencies the
lack of water has had a knock-on effect
with poor sanitation increasing and
ramping up disease
every day's a fight to eat and to live
and these are the ones who've made it to
the main southern city and help
we travel through the south the worst
hit region the country's one of the most
bio-diverse in the world with a unique
ecosystem and species not found anywhere
else on earth but it's now struggling
there's very little infrastructure with
mostly unpaved roads and many
communities extremely remote so what aid
there is is difficult to deliver
the extreme weather includes multiple
yearly cyclones and dust storms making
subsistence farming even tougher and
people are becoming more and more
desperate
these young herdsmen didn't want to be
interviewed
but picking up rocks and waving their
farming tools they demand money to let
us through
and then sit down in front of our
vehicles and refuse to budge until we do
our malagasy colleagues begin
negotiations as the herdsmen tell them
they're hungry and they need money for
food our drivers reluctantly hand over
cash
when we reach marofu the village elder
in orange is appalled at the attempted
hold up raids on the migo crops are on
the rise here
he's anxious to show us how malnourished
the children are and many are showing
signs of acute malnutrition
this is what they've been reduced to
eating cactus flowers which are devoured
very quickly they offer some relief from
hunger pangs but they will bloat their
bellies and cause cramps later
many have blistered lips and the wizard
skin of those three times their age
of course these are not enough for us
but we've no choice hariba tells us
no one has electricity here they cut
trees and burn wood for fuel so many
live in medieval conditions
rohani sua has two wives and two large
families with a total of 16 children to
feed
[Music]
i can't ever fill these bowls with
enough food for them he says and we're
always hungry but i watered the rice
down to make it go further
he shows us his second home a few yards
away he's trying to make stuffing for
mattresses
but he's not sold anything so they'll
eat cactus flowers again he says
the village elder insists on escorting
us out his instincts are correct the
herdsmen have been waiting for us to
leave on the single track out the young
men are scolded as they protest they
need help
everyone is hungry
madagascar has contributed virtually
nothing to the world's annual carbon
emissions but is probably the worst
affected country and its people are
crying out for change alex crawford sky
news madagascar
well scientists predict that uh africa
will be hit harder by climate change
than
any other continent on earth evelyn
asham is a ugandan climate activist and
joins me now thank you for being with us
what does this deal mean for your
country do you think
thank you so much for having me here
my country has been suffering is one of
the countries that are suffering some of
the worst impacts of the climate crisis
but um
we are and yet we are less responsible
for the
for the global co2 emissions but we are
suffering some of the worst impacts and
yet again the decisions made today
yesterday the final decisions made at
corp will only mean more disasters for
us more death for us but again for years
we have been waiting for the 100 billion
u.s dollars that was promised by 2020
but we are not seeing the money yet we
are waiting for the money and we need to
see it and
again besides this 100 billion us
dollars there is no separate fund for
loss and damage my country is already
experiencing loss and damage and so many
other countries so many other poor
countries in the global south we demand
this money and we need to see this money
i mean do you think do you think that
the money will come we've just seen with
kovid that
wealthy countries have promised money to
poorer nations to developing countries
on covid and it's been very slow in
coming do you fear the same will happen
with the climate crisis
i think that money is actually there
it's possible for that money to come but
the leaders are only not having enough
will enough political will to bring this
money but again some countries like um
like scotland have already committed
have already committed to about um two
two million pounds two million pounds
for to for loss and damage so we we call
upon more families to join this for to
join this to uh to provide that money
for loss and damage especially the rich
countries that have already caused this
crisis you are responsible for providing
that loss and damage money and for the
100 billion u.s dollars for the climate
finance we are waiting for the money it
was supposed to have come last year but
we didn't see it and we are waiting for
it and this only means if the money has
not yet come this only means that we
won't stay silent we will keep demanding
for this money because the people are
dying the people are suffering we are
seeing disasters every day everywhere
and we don't have the resources to adapt
to this we do not have the resources for
loss and damage but again there are some
things that we cannot adapt to like
vanessa says we cannot adapt to
extinction we cannot adapt to starvation
so we need to see this money
okay uh evelyn ashram thank you very
much for being with us
well the warning that not enough has
been done in glasgow will be met with
dismay by people in countries around the
world like in uganda for whom the
effects of climate change are already
too real back here in brazil rainforest
cattle are part of a multi-million pound
conspiracy our chief correspondent
stuart ramsey has been to santa rem in
brazil's para state a warning this
report contains pictures of one of the
herd of cattle being mistreated this is
his story on brazil's illegal beef trade
these steers are unregistered and
illegal they have no legitimate markings
some have yellow tags indicating only
that they've been sold
they're from the amazon rainforest from
farms that have no legitimacy the land
has been stolen
but these cattle will eventually enter
the world's food supply chain re-badged
as legal
it's a conspiracy worth millions
beef washing with the amazon at its
heart
the vital link between climate change
and cattle is simple
eighty percent of the forest being cut
down here is carried out by ranchers
the amazon is being destroyed so that
you can eat beef
this is what it looks like when the
farmers move in
the trees simply disappear
never to return
this is para state in the amazon and it
looks like this everywhere you go
brazil is the world's number one
exporter of beef much of it at the
expense of the forest that keeps the
planet breathing
a recent audit of the world's biggest
meat packing company found it had bought
over 300 000 cows from paris state that
had irregularities basically beef washed
into the regular market from rainforest
farms
the animals are transported hundreds of
miles by truck you see them everywhere
you go
there are 210 steer in these two lorries
they've been traveling for seven days
with no food or water
they've been parked here for hours
the metal of the truck is so hot you
can't touch it
farmers tell us that the steers can lose
up to 35 kilograms each just from the
travel
this unregulated and illegal business is
rarely seen
sky news given unparalleled access into
this murky world of beef production by
unrepentant farmers who believe it is
their right
to produce
[Music]
producing a key element protein
to the planet
exhausted from days in a truck for a few
hours these steers arrested before the
next part of their journey a river
transporter barge on a tributary of the
amazon
they're driven towards the metal loading
ramp of the barge
[Applause]
slipping and sliding
with no regulation no controls and
certainly no vets their well-being
appears to be utterly ignored
one of the steers doesn't make it up the
ramp and gets stuck
so began over an hour of brutal efforts
to get him to move
the ranchers start by kicking him in his
face
trying to rile him to stand
clearly in terrible distress the men
then force his head underwater
i hope the steer fearing he is drowning
will be spurred on
the animal must be terrified
he struggles forward and collapses
legs splayed apart
he's badly injured now and he still
isn't on board
anyone who's seen animals being treated
particularly when they're being taken
away to slaughter know that it's pretty
gruesome but this is very nasty
incidents in that animal is absolutely
exhausted the point is it's all part of
unregulated trade
nobody knows where that beef is going to
end up it could be in britain it could
be in europe it could be in argentina it
could be in brazil and that's the real
issue here nobody's across what's
happening and of course
the treatment any of the sort of usual
strictures don't really exist
finally they resort to a block and
tackle
ropes are tied around the horns
and he is slowly hauled into the barge
this beef will eventually be certified
and exported
and none of us will ever know it came
from the rainforest
produced to satisfy demand
stuart ramsey sky news in the amazon
well china is the world's greatest
industrial power and its greatest
polluter president xi jinping didn't
attend the climate summit in glasgow and
it was his negotiators who joined india
in a last minute bid to water down
commitments in the final text tom
cheshire reports now from beijing on
china's crucial role
the world was hoping for a lot from the
planet's biggest polluter or at least
something but china made no new major
pledges at cop26
because that really was the plan all
along just listen to the words of the
man who wasn't there president xi
jinping
since i announced the goals of carbon
peak and carbon neutrality last year
china has formulated an action plan for
carbon dioxide peaking before 2013.
in other words china has its own plan
and it's determined to stick to it no
matter the international pressure
that's especially disappointing on coal
the most polluting fossil fuel
china along with india secured a
last-minute weakening of language on
coal which means it can keep increasing
its coal energy capacity until 2025 as
planned it says the economic costs of
moving away quicker are too great to
bear
but we are where we are and if beijing
won't shift its emission targets the
question then becomes how do we make
sure they're sticking to them
and what it shows you here is for the
chosen period of time what is a carbon
emission change for uh ching zhu is a
researcher at xinhua university in
beijing and also at carbon monitor a
project which aims to create a near
real-time dashboard of global emissions
she says that china is taking its
mission seriously now in china i see a
lot more
not just
like national policies but also
responses from local levels like local
governments are really trying to get an
accurate accounting for their carbon try
to figure out where they can cut the
emission
hopefully without damaging economy and
balancing a lot of factors so i really
see local efforts as well
with countries now asked to return in
2022 to give a report on their progress
up-to-date emissions figures will be
very important
if cop 26 was about words now it's about
the numbers tom cheshire sky news
beijing
well according to a poll conducted for
sky news people in the uk believe in
climate change but are not as willing to
pay more to address the challenge lisa
holland reports from a former mining
area in south wales to gauge the view of
the people
this part of the world owes its history
to coal nobody goes down the pits
anymore and in blind that's taken its
toll but they can feel the climate is
changing
do you think that places like this would
have an uncomfortable relationship with
climate change um to some people yeah
the heritage of this town is the coal
and the iron works
and without that there wouldn't be a
town
a poll for sky news suggests
increasingly there's a reckoning over
global warming 76 percent of people we
spoke to accept the climate is changing
due to human activity but almost
two-thirds said they haven't been paying
attention to the climate change
conference
ten-year-old mason is amongst those who
have been following events
what do you know about cop26 it's doing
it in glasgow and stuff and people are
marching around and all
but blaine avon is altogether less
frenetic and that's part of the
problem back in the day this would have
been a gold rush town now businesses
have closed poverty levels are high and
people are worried about the cost of
living let alone saving the planet
locals admit the electric car bays
aren't used much
sign maker yazia says he's struggling to
find labour to keep his businesses going
from a business point of view
it's all about affordability whether you
can afford to change your vehicles et
cetera et cetera
our survey suggests people are split on
whether taxes should be increased to
help pay the costs of reducing carbon
emissions in britain 44 percent oppose
the idea
obviously with it being milder better
grass
growth sheep farmer james bourne knows
better than most how the seasons have
changed in some respects it's already
too late
i think
that you know in time the world
probably will come together to to make
it to improve things
but i don't think it's something that's
going to happen
you know in the short term
in the
of the minds
where you age
before your time
one thing that's not changed is blind
evan's choir still going after more than
a hundred years
farmer james is a baritone and took us
to meet some other members and their
friends to discuss how habits in the
hillsides are changing
i think that's
in a town like this which is typical of
many towns in britain there's a way we
would put heat pumps on these
on these terraced houses now we've got
food banks and all these towns we've
gone backwards and i think most people
are worried about that and climate
change
in our survey more than two-thirds said
they felt pessimistic that the world
will make the changes necessary to limit
the impact of climate change
i think there's a lot of passion but i
do worry how much of it actually can get
done
the planet needs more than prayers
and as our poll suggests a greater
global willingness for one community to
save another
lisa holland sky news blind
let's bring in our science editor tom
clark from glasgow to sum up where we
are this evening and what happens next
tom
well sally we need to um we need to see
everyone deliver on what they promised
to do here in glasgow they signed up to
this glasgow climate pact there's a lot
of details all the rules that the un uh
put into parts of that in accordance
with the paris treaty they've got to
declare their emissions they've got to
follow those rules but most importantly
they've got to come back in 2022 with
more ambitious targets that is the
crucial part about keeping 1.5 degrees
on the table within reach because right
now it just isn't there yet but most
importantly we also need to watch for
what the rest of the economy does there
were some important announcements here
in glasgow about mobilizing cash about
deals between different nations to phase
out coal about the roll out of electric
cars there's lots that can happen in the
real economy to accelerate things faster
than the un process can move and that
could happen and that's something to
watch for
tom thank you
so while politicians and diplomats have
been meeting in glasgow wrangling over
that agreement i've been traveling to
the world's most important rainforest
and some of brazil's greatest cities it
was often depressing to witness but here
are some of the people i met along the
way many of them doing their bit in
difficult circumstances to fight global
warming
this ecosystem is very important elaine
griffin said
we must fight for this
it's our land
[Music]
the kakama people they've been displaced
by illegal mining and logging and their
language and culture is under threat
[Music]
this is one way to
fight against the climate change very
very very important these trees but it
is not straightforward the disastrous
habits of man are taking their toll here
this is my dream and here is nightmare
they are not only destroying trees here
they're poisoning rivers too
industrial waste chemicals and human
sewage flowing through here this is what
man is doing to one of the greatest and
most important rainforests in the world
so worried of scientists about what is
happening down here below us that they
fear that if it continues in the way it
is
that within a few generations the amazon
rainforest could disappear
it's illegal
but we can't give up
we might fight every day welcome to my
greenhouse greenhouse in a favela
i'm have a dream i want
very very three hoops everywhere it's my
dream
just some of the inspiring people i've
met here across brazil
in what is i have to say an otherwise
pretty depressing picture there is
really no political will here in brazil
uh among the government certainly among
the president at the moment to tackle
climate change and while ordinary
individuals will make a difference it is
politicians it is national leaders who
have the real power to change things
glasgow has come and gone the battle for
the planet goes on
from rio de janeiro in brazil bye-bye